Hi. Welcome to the coding portion of lesson 4.
Now we're going to create some conferences. A conference management
application really needs to be able to create and
save conferences. After we've created some conferences, we're going to
learn how to run queries and use filters to
query those conferences. For example, suppose you've got a trip
planned to San Francisco in June and you want
to find out if there's any conferences going on then.
I'll show you how to write the code to
find out. Then we're going to delve deeper into indexes.
We're going to look at the index configuration file and
then we're going to use the index viewer in the
admin console to explore our indexes, to make sure
that they're serving so that our users don't get index
non existent errors. Another thing our application really needs to
be able to do is to allow users to register
for conference, and the registration process
needs to take place inside a transaction.
Suppose you give us your credit card number, you want to make sure you've
really got a seat before the payment goes through. So, we're going to
use the registration process to practice
writing transactions. Let's go create some conferences.